the animal foundation the topic of a
heated and emotional city council
meeting today Victoria Saha reports from
downtown Las Vegas on this latest
chapter
[Music]
it was a packed house at the Las Vegas
city hall with many Animal Advocates
demanding the city council Take Back
Control of the animal foundation they
say they have had enough of the lack of
transparency and wants what's best for
the animals
Animal Advocates taking a stance
[Applause]
being the voice for the hundreds of
animals the only viable option I see at
this point is for the city to take over
shelter Services the city is in contract
with the animal foundation until 2025
but many former and current staff want
elected officials to step in now I come
to speak to you today to advocate for
Mercy James Pumphrey former CEO of the
animal foundation said he was hired to
assess the foundation and after a
lengthy report of changes and concerns
to be addressed he said he was fired in
July by CEO Hilary gray I was being
asked to be less than transparent the
lack of transparency has been a huge
topic this month with eight staff
members walking out in one day and the
following week animals getting sick due
to respiratory illness these
compassionate Warriors deserve respect
and dignity to be in contract with the
city animals need a clean and Humane
environment we've had several notices
that were affect your school they notice
you know there's just cages and clean
the city is allowed to make unexpected
visits to inspect and give them 48 hours
to respond to an issue or could be under
breach of contract every time we've
brought some to attention they've
corrected within the period we are
committed to being an excellent partner
to developing and training our staff to
creating the best environment for staff
as well as for Animals I asked gray
about any changes to come after hearing
everything today do you think you have
what it takes to make changes under your
leadership at animal foundation we do
I'm proud of our staff and the work that
we've done council members have all
agreed to hire an independent party to
audit the finances at the animal
foundation Victoria Saha eight news now